they go Daniels Daniels for those
closest one la que por la nación y por
lo que pasa hijos they came to like tens
of thousands of Central Americans every
month said here Perry's who's from
Guatemala is attempting to migrate to
the US the biggest challenge used to be
getting across the u.s. border but now
Mexican president and the rest Manuel
Lopez Obrador
has made it increasingly tough even to
get into Mexico since June after Donald
Trump threatened to impose tariffs on
all Mexican exports
he has clamped down hard the numbers
show the policy is working there has
been a more than 75 percent drop in the
number of migrants making it into the US
and Mexico had deported as many people
by October as in the whole of last year
but the Mexico Guatemala border is hard
to police it runs through mountains
jungles and rivers for nearly 900
kilometers and is full of clandestine
crossings I travelled along it to see
the impact of La Paz obradors crackdown
I wanted to try to understand what keeps
driving people like said here to leave
when the chances of success have
narrowed dramatically and to find where
the Mexico's southern border is becoming
a proxy for Trump's border war right now
everyone president Trump saying that the
u.s. is prepared and is at this moment
in time preparing to impose a five
percent tariff on all goods imported
from Mexico if that country doesn't
start to do more to combat the migrant
crisis on our southern border of Peru
lemmas Comoros me military Sando la
Frontera mexico's president had at first
welcomed Central American migrants
fleeing poverty and violence and offered
them humanitarian visas but many used
them just to travel unhindered
Mexico to get to the u.s. Washington has
got tougher signing deals with Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador to force
migrants to seek asylum there first not
in the US but those deals will be hard
to enforce and the pressure is on Mexico
to stay tough as next year's US election
approaches Mr Lopez Obrador knows that
any misstep on the issue of migration
could blow up into by national crisis
Independiente de los equipos de ahora de
aqui a las maletas por lo menos mexico
Wester sujeto nel normal present a
Estados Unidos para mantener una
política restrict IVA muy drastically my
ratio nindo commented I think that this
is going to be a stone in the shoe of
the Mexico us relationship for the rest
of the Trump administration and probably
whoever comes next because migration is
a very sensitive issue in the United
States I mean suddenly becoming a
sensitive issue in Mexico Lopez Obrador
is in a tough spot he regularly hails
Mexicans he migrated to the US in past
decades and sent back record remittances
as living heroes but he's put the need
to protect Mexico's relationships
between us first at udoit Vidal
Financial Times acoustic press too much
attention
busted' unmanifested o mucho interests
para el la situación de los Milan tase
gusta piensa ear a visit our las
estaciones Mira toria's o algunas
alvarez para verificar e para decir m
primera persona que que es lo que mexico
fruss a cerca de la gente de los llanos
tambien pendiente de los migrantes
le diría que todos dias si hace falta a
Cecilia UN albergue a pero se esta
attendee endo bien el asunto
do not pay the smugglers did not pay the
Coyotes do not put yourself in danger do
not put your children in danger all sigh
okay
Estados Unidos assumed by the grantee
you know so love him in today's interim
erica has died
no secretary they are despite the
dangers and increasing difficulties the
people smugglers are still finding ways
to make a profit here in the remote
highlands of Guatemala I've come to meet
one of the go-to guys in this illicit
business to find out what has changed in
the past few months since the crackdown
began Alex
for the past seven years
he says Alex charges $7,500 and says he
makes a profit of about 600 or $700 per
migrant but that's after paying $800 per
person to a drug cartel to deliver them
to the US border check him take me - you
know no Savini Mondays at anta Hinton no
it's almost pocos someone's being
Bastilla
who is he he'll me Graziano Soldado's of
tava Caminos aan de notre Saku Saku no
valet hace dos veces atras donde vamos a
la dejas en aproximadamente
tres mil keen yentas personas bajo Cho
cientos hasta la semana pasada solo en
tres personas y la gente lima grass
Mira como como sorry Glen Cornelius in
RunAs parties you know when Camino
contact us via phone yeah
no no deposited acquaintance yeah person
said here is willing to chance
everything but his job in a shop only
pays five dollars a day and he's only
been able to muster $1,800 so he gives
up the only thing he has the deeds to a
plot of land if he doesn't pay in two
months it will belong to Alex but the
seller was tempted to meet compa parole
note a cappella operator was supposed to
accept and boom pero ESO since you still
owe me complaining and s a tiempo was
directly killed in neurosurgery and tone
says the pseudonym a company in metal
tip okay Ramos yo Puna boya so tearin
ito been there long
oh no saboteur welcome to familia que
venga el dinero por muchas cosas por mi
a salir de panamá que canta Satomi
koh-sama he can get people it was
helpful kids killer alma's he was here
but it's real okay I see a cute thing
coming nothing yeah when I see a kid
while said he was setting out from the
town of quill Co along this bumpy single
track road headed for one of scores of
informal border crossings high in the
mountains
another migrant finally was just
crossing into Mexico the marine Martinez
family was forced to flee from Honduras
after their 18 year old son was murdered
and their home burned to the ground by
local gangs one of the easiest ways into
Mexico used to be across the sushi at a
river that makes up part of the border
with Guatemala but now every person is
being stopped by immigration officials
something that's never really happened
before the Marine Martinez family is
trying a different route but it's along
a main road where police have set up
roadblocks it's already their second
attempt and they are terrified running
into the bushes at the sight of a police
car even though local police tell us
they have no interest in migrants and
it's the federal police they need to
watch out for
see
[Music]
finally father Thomas founder of the
local migrant shelter arrives to rescue
them here 750 miles from home they are
safe and will receive medical care and
legal advice
the children are exhausted and famished
one of the girls is sick Ramon Marcus
runs the shelter it's called the 72 in
honor of 72 migrants murdered by the
drug cartel the setters in 2010
meanwhile estamos llegando quality less
problematic assistant to dallas que esta
cosa nostra plus Anita for Sado Monsieur
Saracen - si la certainty or sketchy
overtaking en la paura see we don't know
chun-hee maybe sem mil personas see so
much about this humanitarian like
estamos hablando Donald Trump's tough
stance has also been boosted by a
Supreme Court ruling in September that
now makes it virtually impossible for
Central Americans to apply for asylum in
the US he has also been pushing asylum
seekers back over the border to wait for
their court hearings in Mexico but Ramon
says that with homicides in Mexico at a
record of some 34,000 last year the
country just isn't safe enough to take
them in la gente que busca de vionnet
pieno di un papel ET un papel para maana
conseguirá dad o para poder initial no
no
in Mexico no Mexico no complications
minima's parle Vergara stock resume
Alitalia e encima a los niveles de
valència in witches parties and pies
into a la Frontera Norte for so
tremendous entrances our final agenda
New Orleans si puede volver encantar
Kuna Valencia tambien and even where it
is we're done Mexico's migration
authorities which have suffered big
budget cuts and a Lopez Obrador
austerity government are struggling with
the sheer numbers and even though Mexico
has a long history of taking in refugees
from civil war and dictatorships in
Spain Guatemala and South America polls
show that public opinion is increasingly
hostile to migrants Mexico says the
answer is development it once Washington
to help fund social programs it's the
right diagnosis but it will take years
and as Trump cuts aid to Central America
getting the u.s. to cough up maybe heart
[Music]
said his American dream quickly turned
into a nightmare he was in a group of
about eleven people trying to cross the
desert nine made it including his
companions from Quebec oh he and two
others were deported back in Guatemala
worried about all the debts he'd racked
up in the fact that he could lose his
land so he o decided to try again he
failed again and was deported for second
time he's given up for now
but migrants like him will keep on
trying out of desperation their chances
of success are increasingly slim
you